hello everyone I'm Renard here am I talk
about parts of parts are combinators for
program transformation so a little bit
about me first
I recently defended my PhD at CMU where
I worked on topics and program
transformation program analysis and
program repair and especially on
automating these techniques so that we
can have things like automatic bug
fixing and large-scale refactoring in
new ways I'm heading off to industry
nets where I'm going to work at a
startup called source graph and here I'm
lucky because I get to work on these
same ideas and develop them in a way
that integrates with you know developer
workflows that you might all be familiar
with like code search code intelligence
and navigation and code review I love
developer tools and my favorite color is
Oh camel so that's me let's talk about
you and what this talk has a mind for
you so as you're probably familiar code
changes code changes all the time
so the Greek philosopher Heraclitus had
these ideas that you know change is the
only constant I'm pretty sure that he
was talking about code change he just
didn't know it so I'm going to jump
right into a demo to kind of demonstrate
you know what kind of code changes do we
perform to make code more readable the
kinds of refactorings that you probably
do every now and then after you know
implementing some new feature so I'm
going to look at an example and go first
and so this is a static check tool that
does all kinds of linting type checks or
static checks I'm not affiliated with
this tool in any way I just like looking
at tools that you know give kind of
idiomatic patterns for expressing
changes for all kinds of languages so
here it turns out and go you can
simplify some our constructions
specifically if you're constructing an
error we're oops that's good there we go
when you're constructing an error you
might write out some formatted string
and you can actually use a dedicated
function called err F to do that instead
so
this is documentation for a tool that
does a lot of things in the underlying
representations and abstract syntax tree
and I'm going to show you how you can
turn documentation like this into an
actionable code transformation that you
just run in your code and to do that
declaratively so Kombi is a tool that i
wrote to do this sort of transformation
so with combi you specify kind of
declaratively what you want to see in
the transformation so in this first
argument on the command line we're just
going to write out this before pattern
and everything is going to be concretely
the same as what you see in that
documentation except for the arguments
of this s printf call which is going to
be bound to some variable some alpha
numeric variable name here I'm just
using the number one enclosed by some
square brackets and a proton to denote
that this is a variable or a hole that
can match this syntax so in the second
argument we write out this after pattern
that we're interested in and we refer to
that variable that we've bound to some
syntax and we're going to specify that
we want to run this on all go files in
the current directory surrounding this
pattern we find one instance in this
source code where we can rename this
function and extract out the argument of
Vesper net and put it in this area of
call so this is actually a example that
I ran yesterday on the go compiler
source code and so if you want a freebie
to go and contribute something to the go
compiler here you go I have not opened a
pull request this has a good chance of
getting accepted it is also the only
pattern that I found in the code base
that exhibits this all right so to just
demonstrate that well that's a preview
and we can actually just perform the
change in place by adding an in place
specifier and then you know in your diff
you're going to see something like this
that you can PR alright so would it be
nice if we had something like this for
any language and I do mean any language
here right so the ability to kind of in
a structured way match and rewrite
syntax without caring too much about the
underlying implementation so what I'd
like you to take away from this talk is
a new way to change code both tooling
and thinking about ways of changing
in a structured way so the way I'm gonna
structure this talk is first kind of
give you a deeper understanding of
program syntax manipulation and
challenges in this areas in terms of
tooling and scaling this idea or
generalizing it across multiple
languages and then going to talk about
my solution for manipulating syntax and
give you some exposure to some neat
ideas and a functional paradigm that
allows this mechanism to work and
throughout I'm going to show you some
practical tooling and demos to show you
kind of the contextual information and
examples that make it relevant to
activities that you are probably engaged
in so being an academic I'm going to
talk about some papers I'm not going to
dive into it deeply but this is an
interesting paper from 1992 on language
design for program manipulation the
point of this paper is just asking the
question well what are sensible choices
for program syntax and to some extent
semantics if the number one concern if
the thing that we cared most about was
the ability to change this program
easily so there's this closing sentence
in this abstract design principles are
suggested so they're problems identified
foreign languages can be avoided
in the future they were not avoided to
give you one example of these principles
here's some concrete syntax on the left
two examples of some if condition in the
body that parse to the same underlying
abstract syntax tree in languages like C
and Java the one has braces the other
does not so we have multiple concrete
syntaxes that now refer to this same
underlying data structure and so there's
this principle that well you know the
concrete syntax diverges from the
objects abstract syntax tree and so
that's not a desirable property if we
care about changing code what that means
practically is you know there's more
work for analysis tools compilers and so
on converting to this representation and
giving it back if you only have the ast
here which concrete syntax do you map
active
I'm not saying that we should not have
ambiguous or different concrete syntax
I'm only pointing out that the choices
that we make in languages that are
convenient sometimes or more readable
have implications and consequences and
the underlying tools and so this can
crop up just for one language what about
multiple languages humans are very
creative and we are no less creative
about writing out and designing
programming languages we are very
inventive you know using different names
different syntaxes to express similar
ideas in different languages and well I
know you're probably only working in one
language at a time but wouldn't it be
nice if we had a consistent experience
an ability to rename or manipulate
syntax across all of the languages that
we use day-to-day and part of this
complexity introduces problems for
tooling maybe you use a language that's
very popular and you have a very rich
tool tool change to choose from but now
maybe no one wrote a tool yet for the
language that you're interested in so
one of the languages that I've recently
started playing with a lot is element
ohm has a lot of really great tools but
there are some changes that I want to
make sometimes to my program that can be
automated and so I'm going to show you
one demo here in elm using my tool where
you can simplify this left-hand pattern
here to the right-hand one so you can
map for example the same function across
the same function we would otherwise do
this at multiple layers on the left hand
side here and I'm going to show you a
demo in a live environment so this is
available online at Kombi don't live and
I'm going to kind of walk you through
how you can develop patterns like these
and then to apply them directly to
source code so first we're going to look
at how to match things that were
interested in so in this case what we're
interested in is this lift up math
pattern and then things after it in the
default case we might have a hole like
this expressing everything after it so
this includes new lines for example but
right now we're actually interested in
just the first argument or function here
and for that there's a slight lead
syntax to match identifiers or
alphanumeric characters using these
double brackets so free changes pattern
a little bit more and extend it you know
to match this typing operation you can
say okay we have consecutive typing for
this list map and we've matched both of
these arguments that were interested in
and now we can rewrite it to this other
form that's a little bit shorter in
which I personally prefer where you can
use just one list up map operation and
then chain these functions using this
function composition operator all right
so again this is now a capability that
you have an elm or a different language
it might not which might not already
have a linting check or a refactoring
tool other times maybe your language of
preference is getting extended so you
have something like Python right
apparently they're getting they might
give a assignment expression soon and so
what if you needed a tool that can
refactor that but that's not yet
integrated into some Python tool chain
and if you're very fortunate you might
have you know powerful tools like crying
that works on your C program but all of
a sudden when you introduce inline
assembly you're out of luck right like
this doesn't parse anymore so this is
why we can't have nice things
people have to implement tools people
have to take into consideration some tax
extensions changes in the representation
and changes in you know whether you use
other features like macros amount
assembly and so on so let me tell you
about nice things right so another way
to perform lightweight some type of
transformation on tooling using the
approach that I'm talking about today so
to take another example we can remove
redundant milk checks in go in this code
fragment so this is again another kind
of syntactic change that you can perform
when you are ranging over this variable
you need not necessarily check whether
it's no if it's a slice or a map
so from this documentation we can
actually just remove that surrounding if
check to produce this for just the for
loop on its own and what I want you to
take away here is that here's the
implementation for this check right I'm
not expecting you to actually read this
and I'm sure if we all had time we could
implement a check like this ourselves
but you have to become familiar with the
underlying AST learn this visitor API
and implement it in your language of
choice and this is a lot of effort if
you're interested in doing the same for
rust C Haskell or your language of
choice so again I'm proposing a solution
here that's syntactically close to the
code that you want to change and when I
got feedback on making these slides
originally the part on the bottom here
is the preferred solution on people tell
me why I don't really see the difference
between the you know the example you're
giving on the under and the actual
change and that's the point right so we
want something closer to syntax but that
can match structurally on things like
nested constructs that regular
expressions are not powerful enough to
do so I'm going to walk you through an
example of writing out a template that
performance is change and kind of the
the properties of doing that so here
I've copied some code again just this
fragment where we're going to match on
this case so in the first part we write
up this if condition and then match on
some expression which I'm just going to
bind to this variable expert and then we
can add these braces so the thing about
cambia is it understands that braces
parentheses brackets these are delimited
by default so if you enter a hole
between these it knows that they should
be balanced this is not like records
where your matching sequences of
characters and hoping to match a
balanced delimiter so it understands
that by default now we can expand this
pattern to then include the part about
the for loop here I'm just calling X to
bind to what's being assigned from the
range we don't really care about it and
then again specify this expert part
which is the hole that refers to the
part that's being checked against right
so the fact that I'm using the same
variable name here means that those two
things must be equal in what they're
binding so we see this test dot slides
being the same thing that's checked
against as the part in the for loop
all right so we've matched the parts
that we're interested in against this
source code and now we can rewrite it so
I just copy this template paste it on
the right hand side here and now we can
rewrite it by simply removing that part
of the code so that's the demo you can
follow you can go through this to
yourself again at the bottom right there
there's a link that has the example
written out for you so this approaches
syntax mommy I am NOT introducing any
knowledge about type information or
variable scoping and that's as a first
pass for enabling a very declarative way
of just manipulating syntax and because
it's syntax only nothing about this
really is go specific so the check of
courses go specific but what I mean is
syntactically there's nothing go
specifically on here for example and
dart you might want to perform this
change where instead of checking I get a
list against whether the zero you can
use a built-in dedicated attribute to
check whether it's not empty and that's
actually more performant compared to a
linear a check that's you know a linear
of the size of the list and the former
part enclosure there are more idiomatic
ways to check things against nil and
installing you might be able to simplify
a a chain of function calls into
something simpler and so all of these
languages support this notion of you
know balanced limiters and expressions
inside of them that we are interested in
renaming and this is relevant because in
general we can't use regular expressions
to do the sort of thing who is familiar
with this post on Stack Overflow a lot
of you okay good if you're not do check
out this URL or just search like Stack
Overflow red X HTML parts right regular
expressions are not good at parsing
structured languages especially nested
languages and I love how this pans
because it's just like you know have you
tried using an XML parser instead we use
parsers to parse languages not not
regular expressions so in order for a
purse like this to work and to actually
you know apply to multiple
we need a parcel for multiple languages
so now I'm going to go into a little bit
more technical detail about what
underpins this approach and what it
allows it to work
so in this parser for multiple languages
identify that there are shared context
free language properties what are
context-free language properties things
like balance the limiters violence
parentheses braces and so on this syntax
fundamentally delineate trees right so
blocks or lots of diff conditions and so
on and so a way to achieve building a
purser from multiple languages is to say
well at a high level let's take
something like a parentheses language so
a grammar that can generate you know
phrases in this language that are always
balanced with respect to parentheses and
extend it in a way that models modern
languages so there's a bit of math
involved here if you're interested in
the math you can go check out a paper
that was published at peel di in June I
don't want to go too much more into the
math but the point is that we need a
more principled way to deconstruct
languages so that we don't run into this
problem right so a simple grammar
respecting this kind of structure I'm
showing up here so all that this grammar
is going to do for us is it's going to
parse things that are balanced with
respect to delimiter x' and everything
else is going to be treated as a token
so to give a practical example let's
take some go code of hello world and we
can decompose this with respect to the
limiters according to this grammar so it
looks like this it includes white space
so this func
main part in the beginning that's one
token according to this grammar the only
things that we care about that's
deconstructive are things between and
inside de limiters and that's what this
grammar expresses as a first pass this
is useful for identifying these kinds of
patterns so that we can rewrite them at
a structural level now there's more
details in the paper about how we
deconstruct with respect to white space
or punctuation and so on but at a high
level
that's that's the important part so I
told you how to represent code so that
we can achieve transformations like
these but how do we actually match
declarative templates to source code so
given some template how do we achieve
this ability to match and find things
that were interested in so show of hands
how many people are familiar with parser
Combinator's have used libraries or read
about them okay great I'm at the right
conference if you're not this is your
one sentence summary of what a parser
Combinator is so it's a parser model as
a function that can be composed using
other higher-order functions to
implement your grammar so person
Combinator's are interesting because we
can implement a function that serves as
a parser for an int so given some input
produces an int a parser that you know
given some input produces a string we
can combine these parser dominators and
produce a parser that parses an
expression and parser Combinator's are
very interesting because they're pulling
morphic in their production meaning we
can really write a parser for almost
anytime including courses so we can
write a parser for purses and really
that's the underlying mechanism that
achieves this ability to do to match
declarative templates to source code so
this template is actually something that
defines a parser now before I go into
the next part this is just the secret
sauce right the underlying mechanism of
what makes this approach work you don't
need to actually understand any of this
or write a parser to use the tool it's
for your intellectual curiosity so all
of these languages are already supported
at some level with respect to string
syntax common syntax and delimiter
stright so no need to worry too much
about you know how do I figure this
thing out how do i you this is for your
intellectual curiosity so let's dig into
this a little bit more given some import
mplet what happens underneath the hood
is well as we parse this template we see
oh there's an if if we person if we
produce a parser for an if if you parse
some whitespace we
is a white person for some whitespace
identify this whole produce a parser
that matches and stores text according
to what that whole respects so maybe
alphanumeric characters maybe everything
up to this not equals no we press braces
they should be balanced and we produce a
parser for balanced braces and do that
recursively when we chain all of these
partials now you have one single parser
that expresses exactly what you're
interested in matching hand you can just
run it on the source code if that
pressure succeeds you've matched
something I know you can rewrite and so
that's the underlying reason why I call
this pressure parser Combinator's
because what you're doing is you have
one partial Combinator that produces
other parsers to match the underlying
sentence and what ain't one interesting
kind of side effect of this is that
there is no definition of an ast here at
the code level there's only functions
and parsers that define what you're
interested in matching so that's cool
but where's the complexity right so why
doesn't this tool already exist why
can't I just do this for for a lot of
languages already so let's look at some
code but let's treat this textually so
those parentheses are balanced ignoring
you know the top part if we thought
about comments okay there are some
balanced parentheses if we don't know
what comments are and if this isn't C
code well you know in Piketon this is
this is a different syntax for comments
what does this mean if we treat texts as
sequences of characters we're not we
don't know anything about the knowledge
of or distinction between code and data
an editor is going to highlight some of
these things for you and you and you
know conceptually we think of things in
this way but if we're actually
interested in matching things like
arguments or comments or strings and
using regular expressions well this is
only going to end up with more problems
right and if you do this for for these
complicated code examples with varying
syntax this is not just like turning 99
problems into 100 it's like order
is more so to give you an example of how
this pans out in the actual tooling I'm
going to show you a very quick demo
where suppose we treated this fragment
of JavaScript or typescript code as text
which Kombi cannot also do and we want
it to match on say conditions following
an if statement so here we're matching
everything inside possible comments
inside card and inside data or the
string that you see below here and what
you can do is actually change the target
language that you're interested in so
currently text was selected and we can
select something like JavaScript or
typescript instead in this live double
of the environment which corresponds to
some no command-line option that you can
specify when you're running this on your
code base and then doing that change
will help can be recognized okay there's
only one part here that actually refers
to code now if we're actually cared
about matching strings what we can do is
we can enclose the whole inside of
string quotes and because Chrome via
understands kind of the structure and
syntax for strings it can identify the
string contents here and if we knew the
contents of the string that we were
interested in maybe we'd want to match
on something like if and ignore the
parts around it so those underscore is
just ignoring parts before and after the
string that we're interested in in here
and so we can match on that same
condition inside the string so there's
this distinction between code data and
whitespace or comments so to implement
this complexity and support you know
more than 20 languages in this way is
really done with small parsers that
handle these syntax idiosyncrasies
across multiple languages so here's the
definition for go basically it only
specifies that there are balance
limiters there's some syntax for strings
and some syntax for comments and that's
all you need and that's also the extent
of expressivity that's available to you
for matching and these small definitions
embed into a larger parsers skeleton
that give you that
for matching and rewriting code so
that's all of the tooling I'm going to
transition over to talking about
applying some of these ideas in the real
world and at scale so as part of kind of
validating the approach and
applicability I took the top 100 github
repositories for 12 languages I wrote
one to three of these rewrite rules or
patterns that already exists on mentors
checkers or refactoring tools and so I
applied this to over a quarter billion
lines of code and that takes about 42
minutes on 20 course so the approach is
quite fast you can run this on quite
large code bases just on your laptop of
these changes made pull requests to over
50 unique repositories merge over 40 of
them if you want more examples of the
patterns or the actual code that was
merge you can check out the URLs at the
bottom just one example of such a change
in the russ compiler so they were about
I think 60 instances of redundant uses
of referring to variables using a struct
field and so you can just remove that if
if they are the same name all right so
as a final demo before wrapping up the
top I want to show you a little bit more
advanced capabilities for factorings
that people have run into giving me
feedback on the approach so in this part
I was looking for examples where I could
show something representative for
rewrite rules that can nest and so what
I did was I looked at some popular
Haskell programs and I looked at the
commits that used this and search for
commits that committed things with h9 or
the Haskell inter and what I found was
that there was this interesting case
where you can rename a concatenated list
of strings and just use an infix
operator to append these strings instead
so that's an example of a DIF that I'm
going to show you
for rewriting so I copied this over to
the slide environment and the first part
is just matching on this concatenation
of strings so we're interested in the
body of this list that's being
concatenated and then in the rewrite
part well we're not going to need this
contact part so the first part that here
is to remove the concat and we're no
longer going to care about the list
brackets in there since we're going to
use the interest operator to concatenate
so now the question is well we have this
list we need to rename those commas to
the infix operator so how can we do that
because there are multiple repetitions
of these things inside the list so combi
has a little bit more advanced uses
where you can specify rules to do this
one of these rules is to rewrite in
place this the contents of this variable
and so it's quite simple it's just a
recursive application of this original
pattern that we have and what's going on
is that we'll just map this come out to
this infix operator plus plus and so
just to demonstrate when we change this
right-hand side of the rewrite it
changes in place for the code all right
so again we can copy that pattern and
run it on the code base and then get a
lot of output sometimes you want to run
a formatter to reinvent the code for
example there's also ways to manipulate
the white space indentation in combi
there's more examples of that if you're
interested let me know after the talk
all right so we have a lot of dips and
we can actually apply this change
shortcut so in summary the first time
our eyes to talk if you're interested in
that you link check out the github or
let me know if you're interested in
maybe you know running these patterns in
an editor in your CI these are
definitely things that I am in the
process of exploring so in summary I
told you about language design for
program manipulation things that make
this space hard especially for support
across multiple languages just in terms
of syntax
and breaking down syntax in a way that
makes it possible to recognize things
that you're interested in changing I
presented a simple grammar that can
deconstruct programs for most languages
in a way that makes it amenable for
matching I'd then I then described how I
layer on top of this a way to match
programs declaratively using templates
and the way this is implemented
underneath the hood is with parser
Combinator's that are generated from
parsers by person this input template
and that actually removes a lot of
complexity because you can just define
parsers for the different parts of
syntax that make this whole process
troublesome I shared some of our results
with applying this to large-scale
programs and online and then I gave you
a lot of demos but hopefully gave you a
taste of how the approach works so that
you could use it yourself
I'm happy to take any questions and
thank you for your time yes so the
question so the question was have I
thought about using this for code
highlighting because those approaches
tend to use regular expression patterns
and so how about code the answer is yes
I thought about it no I have not
actually implemented anything for it I
believe it would be fast enough and be
it would be more useful there's
definitely some curt that you could view
on github that breaks and you can see
that manifest and I think this would
definitely be able to handle that
complexity and also do it efficiently
enough so definitely something worth
exploring yes
I think as a as a priority large scale
refactoring is well I think the real
benefit lies the ability to completely
stomp out write certain code patterns
that are just known to be bad or buggy
and can't be rewritten in different ways
wouldn't that be like great right
there's so many opportunities I realized
during this work for you know just
making Kurt better in it in a very
consistent way so I think large-scale
code modification is is where the the
largest kind of benefit is at an
individual level I really see this also
integrating with editors right so there
there's a place here where it's great in
the CI pipeline but I think a lot of
this stuff can be preventative and that
not so much reactive and so I'm also
focusing on well a it's sufficient
enough to running an editor right so
there's really stuff that we're
targeting where it's like you know under
a 100 millisecond 200 millisecond run
timing you have a catalogue of changes
that maybe you care about and so I think
there's a lot of opportunity there at an
individual level yes yeah
so the question was are there cases
where transformations would change the
code and it wouldn't compile or wouldn't
be correct so this is a really
interesting question and kind of I'm
doing follow-up research in this area
because it's great to have a very
powerful way to change code but that
obviously means that you know you have
more opportunity to mess things up I'll
give you a good concrete example so that
if mil check that I assured you forgo
code well that only applies to maps and
slices it turns out and go you can also
do the same kind of pattern on pointers
but you wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
rewrite that code if it was a pointer so
what it what additional information do I
need I need to know type information for
example so there are many examples
actually where you can transfer code
only if you know the type and you can't
tell what the type is just by looking at
the syntax so there's I already have
ideas on extending this to also
incorporate type information to say okay
perform this try
if I know the thing that was mash here
is of type int or a stream or pointer
and that would incorporate into the the
rules framework so that's one concrete
example malformed syntax that can also
happen right but there there's less up
less possibility of generating malformed
syntax because you can't always not you
can't match them for example unbalanced
parentheses or expressions so there's
some built-in control there that gives
you more confidence about what you're
matching at a syntactic level you have a
follow-up question we have time yes
depends what you mean by a library it's
available as a command-line tool if you
want bindings I believe there are Python
bindings that we have in the work I'm
not sure exactly what other form you
would would want C bindings might be
something that can be supported feel
free to open a bit up issue it is
implemented in ocala yes definitely a
use case that I have been interested in
and thinking of one concrete example is
CoffeeScript and I think that last
example that I showed where you want to
you know also transform things say
inside a list so separators and that
sort of thing
you really need that kind of capability
to do a richer set of transpiling I have
a not tried to apply it in it like a
large large use case scenario but I
believe there's a lot here that could be
done to make that successful thank you
so the good news is it's always going to
parse right now if your macros for
example contain unbalanced parentheses
you can kind of inform the parser that
are just ignore macros for now right so
you could treat macros as a comment and
then it's just going to be ignored now
if you're interested in actually
changing macros and not the rest of the
program just use a different parser or
language that understands ok macros can
be unbalanced or what now identify those
parts of the code in fact there's some
interesting research at CMU where we
have one professor that there's a lot of
work in macros and so one interesting
thing is that it's actually bad to have
macros that aren't balanced in some
sense and so you could use this approach
to actually identify markers that are
unbalanced as well so there's there's a
trade-off here where you can basically
use the parser to identify the parts of
the program that you're interested in
okay let's go from the front to the back
yes
question was is there an application
possibility here for symbolic formulas
for example yeah so you know take
something like SMT R sat solvers if that
was maybe one one form of syntax that
you that you'd be interested in yeah
right for example in normalization
routines to simplify various parts of
this this tree that sort of possibility
exists right so so one idea that I've
also had us to take input and from
source code and just convert it for
example directly to something like data
log as a declarative method of
translation let's go
yeah you would write a colon followed by
square brackets Katrine
oh the colon
so the colons square bracket syntax so
it's a good question so the question is
okay can I can I escape the syntax that
I'm using here the medicine tax that is
finding variables so in practice what's
interesting is that we haven't found any
conflicts in practice with code using
that syntax now there are ways to escape
it but the thing to point out here is
that actually it's only valid in this
case when there are alphanumeric
characters inside right that's the only
time combi is going to recognize it as a
variable there's anything else if it's
empty if it's has an expression then
it's not considered a variable so I
think your CoffeeScript use case
wouldn't run into this issue got it okay
that may be a case where you didn't just
get it thank you
so the question was how to combine kind
of these templates into one maybe a
pipeline that you'd run after each other
so there's a couple of options here the
way you would do this in practice right
is one input format for this is you
create a directory for each
transformation you're interested in
create sub directories that say okay
this is the match this is the rewrite
and you can specify this and compy will
take that directory and recursively look
at all the directories with their
naturally right patterns and then apply
all of them in that sequence that the
directory structure isn't so sometimes
you want an ordered sequence and so you
can also use the directory as an
alphabetic sorting method to sequence
those rewrites so there's more of that
in the documentation on the on the
website so that's how you would do it in
practice internally right now it's just
performing each one at a time
so one optimization in the future that
I'm working on is actually just
combining that into one big parser
function right that you just run and
that's going to give some efficiency
gains thank you things like so the
question was has this been proposed for
things like migrations for code bases
may be things like libraries that change
or functions that are deprecated
absolutely I think this is like a key a
key application space or a factoring and
deprecating like updated library calls
this is again tying in to that idea of
large-scale code modifications so really
getting rid of a lot of these patterns
and so Google does this they have really
good in general tools for doing this and
for doing it for example for C code
specifically or Java here I'm
identifying like a lot of opportunities
maybe in languages that are that have
less full-fledged support and definitely
that's one of the applications that it
would be useful for yes we are done
thank you so much everyone for your time
come talk to me